European citizens have been victims
do not simply have information
but an orchestrated campaign of
disinformation you had to remain this
challenge of bills the
opposing groups be stable and I smash in the
parliaments cometti sun european
democracy and which is how is free fr à
0  email
except obvious and once again capital
what do we do if this democratic game is
exhausted if a
hostile power decides to instrumentalize
social networks to instrumentalize
certain political forms to use
the holes that exist in our
legislation on  financing of
political parties to skew this game
to finally subvert our
democratic rules and well in this case
we realize our
weaknesses and this commission makes it
the goal is to respond to the weaknesses
of European democracy does not become a
threat any time after  new york the
specials
i zapped with as a hero boosting an
investigation after noon character soul music
we know today that there are
political movements which present themselves
as
anti-European union and which
work actively with foreign powers
,
we know that this is the case in italy that this
is the case in austria that it  is
also the case in France it is the honor of
our political group to have proposed
this commission it is the honor of
our political group not to have
zapped not to have said bah finally
such elections such election such
election
there was a problem of interference it's
not serious we're moving on
now it's to have pressed the
pause button and to have said we have
to create a special commission
whose goal is to  to establish an inventory
and then to propose concrete tools
which make it possible to preserve
our democratic framework
we have spoiled obama differed competitors
from tourists
we our role as representative
of the European general interest
and indeed it is to guarantee the  fact that this
I  a democracy can continue to
exist
and for that it must be protected
[Music]